in the lobby of Ramsey solutions of
their hair David and Amanda welcome how
are you I did welcome welcome where do
you guys live Philadelphia Pennsylvania
all the way to Nashville to do your
debt-free screen yeah that's actually I
cut of our home base but we travel
full-time for his jobs so he actually
kind of came from New York to Philly to
Chicago to here so what do you do David
I am an inspector for the oil gas and
power industry okay all right so that
keeps you moving a lot yeah absolutely
very cool got it so how much debt have
you two paid off it is thirty five
thousand three hundred and fifty six
dollars and sixty two cents I love it
and how long did that take you it took
us eight months but we put off a month
so it was really seven this cash flow or
tiny RV okay fun and what kind of
household income during that eight
months average per year average per year
I would say it was 130 yeah kind of
fluctuates so just during that time we
brought home about 80 like in that time
span okay all right Wow so what kind of
debt was the 35,000 well my student
loans probably the big massive majority
of that but we also had my vehicle that
was also a little bit of that and a
personal loan that I got to get my
vehicle
some stupid days I'm stupid I like
random little ones how long have you two
been married we are actually celebrating
our one-year anniversary okay so that's
how this journey starts then yes we get
married and David who's uber
conservative marries Amanda who's got a
bunch of dad and then we sit down trying
to figure this mess out is this how the
journey happens tell us about it well in
fairness
he actually was kind of unbeknownst to
you and your plan he was paying off debt
when we got engaged so all of his debt
happened to be paid off before so he did
kind of have that belly so he enters
into this knowing what he's getting into
all right so what tell me what happened
so basically
we got married went on a honeymoon had a
great time came back and he went back to
work he travels a lot so I stayed home
and I was just shopping Ives you would
have loved me I was walking around
target with my latte in hand and just
looking to spend money and I came across
the Dave Ramsey told him Total Money
Makeover and I remember hearing about it
and we just talked recently um maybe one
of the fights money fights but about
just how we're handling and managing our
money so I saw it picked it up and I
read it right there in the aisle ended
up sitting down on the crown just kind
of reading through it and and when I
read the like what this book is not
section
I just got it was common sense it was
stuff that should everyone should be
saying but wasn't saying so I bought it
right then and there I read it that
night and the part that made me want to
introduce that to David was when I was
on my honeymoon my uncle passed away
very suddenly and it just was
interesting to bring someone into the
family and move someone so quickly and
excuse me but so I read one of the
stories in there where there was a
family going through a situation where
there was a very sick husband and you
ran into them in the lobby of a hospital
and they were actually thanking you and
I just thought like wow what a legacy
that that panhu passed away um left his
family and stuff and so with all that
stuff it just felt like God was saying
something and I needed to share it with
David and he took it with open arms he
read the book instantly as soon as I
asked him I was a little nervous to
bring it up but he instantly read it and
was on board well probably wasn't hard
to get him on boards got the way thanks
anyway well actually when I first did
you can take tell him bite she was
trying to convince me to read it in the
first thing in my head was just another
get-rich-quick scheme yeah okay oil
salesman
how much money does he want but actually
I took it to work and I was able to all
my breaks read it and go through and see
that it was it was just common sense
you didn't of stuff you were already
doing absolutely yes and it just fell
into place
perfect perfect so you start your
marriage off completely debt-free or
within eight months anyway yes and we I
mean we went gizelle intense we we took
it and we got out of our apartment fill
the Philadelphia area is rather
expensive so we got out of it we bought
a 20 year old 19 foot trailer which is
about the size of my Jeep Liberty that
pulled it and we lived in that little
thing with my black lab or our black lab
and our cat so the four of us in this
tiny tiny space just making it work is
that intense so you're just following
him around to work with that exactly yes
so now that you're debt-free what are
you gonna do you're still in the trailer
well right now because it's winter we
his work provides hotels so in a hotel
right now but um it's kind of amazing
like we get to do whatever we want next
you know it's kind of we just setting up
our plans next baby stuff you know we've
got a got a plan we got a future it's
great very cool that is so great to hear
you say that one of your sacrifices was
when with with your living conditions
with your I mean that's such a huge part
of people's budget and you guys did that
and so inspiring gizelle intense those
who are listening in they think that
they're gizelle intense but you've got
to another level I was gonna ask you you
know it's 5,000 a month and I mean
that's a that's a big deal yeah I knew
that had to be something really big
there so yes we on that was probably one
of the hardest parts was like my fear of
judgment you know like newlywed bride
and Here I am in a little trailer that's
to do smaller than my car and and you
know I like getting my hair and nails
and makeup and all that had to just stop
out of nowhere and my family and friends
probably thought we were going off the
deep end and wait letting ourselves go
Dave
if you're not Kevin got your in-laws a
little scared you're not congratulations
you guys how does it feel feels amazing
you know it feels like I was sick and I
didn't know it and I finally got the
cure like I didn't realize how much pain
I had like and it wasn't even you know
this tremendous amount of debt but even
like just owing a dollar it just it
stinks it you know it you really do feel
like a slave to that lender and it it
just felt like I've been cured is that's
way to describe it that's a cool thing
what was the hardest part of this I
think you probably covered it that dry I
think the hardest part for me was just
giving up the luxuries that you make so
much money you think you're entitled to
so much but giving all that up and I
think that was actually the hardest part
for me yeah it is it's this dramatic
what Chris was pointing out your
dramatic change and lifestyle and you
know and it's not even so much just
about the debt as important that is I
mean our whole life changed me we've got
him life insurance and now we're working
on getting me and like we'll set up and
I mean just it's it's this whole
transfer tape transformation it's a big
picture it's you go into it thinking all
pay off some loans and then it's like oh
wow I changed my life yeah there's all
these different elements and all the
sudden you're looking around going ahead
got mama grown up congratulations you
two
very very well done David and Amanda
Philadelphia Pennsylvania sorta $35,000
paid off in eight months making a
hundred and thirty thousand you want
ghazal intense you got a picture of it
right here you guys are incredible count
it down let's hear a debt-free scream
three two one
I'm you two very very well done I love
it I love it I love it
Chris I'm not sure when I married Sharon
Ramsey if I had suggested moving into a
travel trailer because of a book I read
that that would have flown I'm telling
you I'm not thinking Hollies going there
Holly's not going there either major
props to Amanda she's the real deal yeah
pretty cool that that's pretty amazing
you kind of look at it though as an
adventure don't you yeah yeah just a
short period of time
there's only eight months they gonna do
anything they want to do now the rest
their life they have no data base like
130 grand they're in their 20s I mean
that's future's bright we get the luxury
of seeing them here in the lobby but
even those listening they can hear it in
their voice yeah the freedom it's here
this is the Dave Ramsey show you know
why most people don't win they don't
bother you have to bother it to be
intentional never again as American
Express gonna call my house and ask my
wife why she would stay with a man that
won't pay his bills
you